>>> A PROMISE TO SEND MIGRANTS
NORTH GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS WHO
INJECTED HIMSELF INTO THE FIGHT
ON IMMIGRATION.
PEOPLE ON MARTHA'S VINEYARD WERE
UNAWARE.
THEY HAD LITTLE MORE THAN THE
CLOTHES ON THEIR BACKS.
DeSANTIS SAID THIS IS JUST THE
BEGINNING, AND HE'S NOT ALONE.
THE WHITE HOUSE WORKING ON A
RESPONSE ACCUSING THE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS OF PLAYING POLITICS
WITH HUMAN BEINGS.
ATHENA, THEY FLEW MIGRANTS, WHO
WEREN'T IN THE STATE TO BEGIN
WITH; IS THAT RIGHT?
>> Reporter: HI, JIM.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THIS IS PART OF A LONG TERM PLAN
THAT RON DeSANTIS HAS BEEN
TEASING FOR MONTHS.
THIS IS A NEW ONE, SENDING THEM
TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
BACK IN A DECEMBER NEWS
CONFERENCE, HE TALKED ABOUT
MIGRANTS TO DELAWARE, PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S HOME STATE, OR MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
HE SAID IF YOU DID SO, YOU WOULD
SOLVE THIS BORDER ISSUE
OVERNIGHT.
THE REAL CONCERN AMONG THE
LEADERS OF THE STATES THAT ARE
RECEIVING THE MIGRANTS IS THE
LACK OF COORDINATION.
BUT THAT IS CLEARLY PART OF THE
PLAN FROM GOVERNORS LIKE RON
DeSANTIS TO SPRING THIS ON THESE
COMMUNITIES FROM WASHINGTON,
D.C. TO CHICAGO, TO NEW YORK, TO
NOW MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
LET'S HEAR FROM A LAWYER WHO WAS
HELPING SOME OF THE MIGRANTS AND
THEN FROM GOVERNOR DeSANTIS.
>> THEY WERE LIED TO AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
AND FRAUDULENTLY INDUCED TO
BOARD THE PLANES.
THEY WERE TOLD THERE WAS A
SURPRISE PRESENT FOR THEM AND
THAT THERE WOULD BE JOBS AND
HOUSING WAITING PORE THEM WHEN
THEY ARRIVED.
THIS WAS OBVIOUSLY A SADISTIC
LIE.
NOT ONLY DID THEY KNOW THERE WAS
NO HOUSING AND EMPLOYMENT A
WAITING THE MIGRANTS, THEY VERY
INTENTIONALLY CHOSE NOT TO CALL
AHEAD.
>> SO THEY HAVE BEEN IN TEXAS
IDENTIFYING PEOPLE THAT ARE
TRYING TO COME TO FLORIDA.
AND THEN OFFERING THEM FREE
TRANSPORTATION TO SANCTUARY
JURISDICTIONS.
AND SO THEY WENT FROM TEXAS, TO
FLORIDA, TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD
WITH A FLIGHT.
THERE WILL BE BUSES AND LIKELY
MORE FLIGHTS.
>> THERE WILL LIKELY BE MORE
FLIGHTS BECAUSE HE SECURED $12
MILLION IN THE STATE BUDGET FOR
MIGRANT RELOCATION.
APPARENTLY THAT MONEY CAN GO TO
RELOCATING MIGRANTS WHO WEREN'T
EVEN IN FLORIDA.
THEY GOT THEM IN SAN ANTONIO.
THEY ENDED UP IN MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
IT IS CLEARLY PART OF A LARGER
STRATEGY, JIM.
>> ATHENA JONES, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
REPUBLICAN STRATEGIST ALICE
STUART AND MARIA CARDONA.
THE WHITE HOUSE CALLING THIS
CRUEL.
IT APPEARS -- IT SOUNDS LIKE
JUST LISTENING TO EVERYBODY THAT
MANY OF THE MIGRANTS WERE MISLED
ABOUT WHERE THEY WERE BEING
TAKEN.
THEY WERE TRICKED INTO THE BUSS
AND ON PLANES.
IS THIS THE BEST WAY FOR
REPUBLICANS TO SHINE A LIGHT ON
THIS ISSUE.
>> WHAT'S CRUEL IS THE FACT THAT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS HAD
THEIR HEAD IN THE SAND ON THIS
FOR MONTHS.
AND THE DAYS OF THEM PLAYING
BAGHDAD BOB WITH THE CRISIS AT
THE BORDER ARE OVER.
WHEN YOU HAVE POLICIES IN PLACE
WITH THIS ADMINISTRATION WITH
REMAIN IN MEXICO AND TITLE 42
WHICH SENDS A WELCOME WAGON TO
IMMIGRANTS TO COME INTO THIS
COUNTRY, YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THEY ARE PROCESSED AND TAKEN
CARE OF PROPERLY.
THE BORDER TOWNS OF TEXAS AND
ARIZONA AND ALSO PARTS OF
FLORIDA, THEY SHOULD NOT BE
SUBJECTED TO THE UNDUE BURDEN OF
CARING FOR THESE PEOPLE ON THE
BASIS OF PROXIMITY.
I THINK THE PROPER THING TO DO,
THIS IS AN ADMINISTRATION
PROBLEM.
THEY DO NOT WANT TO DEAL WITH.
THE GOVERNORS WERE CORRECT IN
MAKING SURE THIS IS AN AMERICAN
PROBLEM AND LET OTHERS BEAR THE
BURDEN.
>> THE BORDER, ALICE, WAS NOT
SECURED DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY SEPARATED CHILDREN FROM
THEIR MOTHERS AS A DETERRENT
BECAUSE THE BORDER WAS NOT
SECURE AT THAT POINT.
WHY WEREN'T DeSANTIS AND ABBOTT
PUTTING LITTLE KIDS ON BUSES
THEN?
>> LOOK, THE POINT IS, THE
BURDEN SHOULD NOT BE ON ANY
SPECIFIC PLACE OR ANY CERTAIN
STATE OR CITY.
AND THE CRISIS HAS GOTTEN
TREMENDOUSLY WORSE.
THE CUSTOMS AND BORDER PATROL
ARE ON TRACK TO DEAL WITH 2.3
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS COMEING INTO
THIS COUNTRY.
THE NUMBERS ARE STAGGERING.
IT'S JUST TOO MUCH FOR THE
BORDER STATES TO HANDLE.
>> MARIA, DO YOU THINK THE WHITE
HOUSE IS DOING ENOUGH ON THIS?
SHOULD THEY GET MORE ENGAGED?
DO THEY NEED TO GO AFTER THESE
STATES, PUT A STOP TO THIS?
>> I THINK THEY NEED TO GO AFTER
THESE GOVERNORS.
THIS IS PERSONAL TO ME AND SO
MANY AMERICANS IN THIS COUNTRY,
AS YOU KNOW, JIM.
I AM AN IMMIGRANT.
AND BUT FOR THE GRACE OF GOD AM
I IN MY FAMILY.
THEY ARE PROCESSING THESE FOLKS
AT THE BORDER.
AND THIS IS WHAT IS SO VIAL,
TWISTED AND CORRUPT ABOUT WHAT
THESE GOVERNORS ARE DOING.
THE BORDER PATROL AND DHS AGENTS
THAT PROCESS THESE FOLKS HAVE
NOW LET THEM GO.
AND THEY WERE GOING TO GO TO
WHERE THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS WERE.
THAT PROCESSING OCCURRED.
THEY ARE NOW BEING LIED TO.
THESE GOVERNORS ARE BEING
DECEITFUL.
THEY ARE ACTING AKIN TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS AND ABDUCTORS.
THEY ARE TELLING THESE MIGRANTS
THEY ARE GOING TO BE REUNITED
WITH THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS.
THEY ARE TELLING MIGRANTS THEY
HAVE JOBS READY FOR THEM,
HOUSING READY FOR THEM.
THEY ARE TELLING THE MIGRANTS IF
THEY DON'T GET ON THESE BUSES,
THEIR ASYLUM CLAIMS MAY NOT BE
HEARD.
I HAVE TALKED TO THEM.
THEY ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE THAT EXIST IN OUR
SOCIETY.
THEY ARE NOT HERE ILLEGALLY BY
THE WAY.
WE HAVE A LAW THAT SAYS IF YOU
ARE AFRAID FOR YOUR LIFE YOU CAN
COME INTO THIS COUNTRY.
THEY ARE COMING THROUGH LEGAL
PORTS OF ENTRY.
THEY ARE NOT SNEAKING IN.
THEY ARE PRESENTING THEMSELVES
TO BORDER CONTROL, WHICH IS THE
PROCESS UNDER THE LAW, AND THEY
ARE SEEKING ASYLUM.
THESE GOVERNORS ARE PUTRID,
CORRUPT, VIAL.
I THINK THEY'RE CRIMINAL AS
WELL.
AND THEY ARE TREATING THESE
MIGRANTS LIKE TRASHING
SECOND-CLASS CITIZENS.
AND THEY ARE SAYING TO THEM, WE
HATE YOU.
WE DON'T WANT YOU.
AND I BELIEVE THIS IS A HUGE
MESSAGE TO ALL LATINO VOTERS IN
THIS COUNTRY, TO ALL IMMIGRANT
VOTERS IN THIS COUNTRY, WATCH
OUT.
TODAY, IT'S THESE MIGRANTS.
TOMORROW, IT'S GOING TO BE YOU.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK, ALICE?
SHOULD REPUBLICANS WATCH OUT
OVER THIS?
>> I THINK DEMOCRATS NEED TO
WATCH OUT AND ACKNOWLEDGE THERE
IS A CRISIS AT THE BOARDER AND
DO WHAT WE CAN TO SECURE THE
BORDER AND ENFORCE EXISTING
IMMIGRATION LAWS.
LOOK, CUSTOMS AND BORDER CONTROL
NUMBERS SHOW NEARLY 70% OF THESE
ARE ECONOMIC MIGRANTS.
SO THEY DON'T QUALIFY AND ARE
NOT QUALIFIED AS SEEKING ASYLUM
FOR REASONS THAT MANY OF THE
MODERN TRIANGLE ARE.
>> THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO ASK
FOR IT, AND THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
THEN THEY WILL BE PROCESSED F.
THAT'S THE CASE, ALICE, IF WHEN
THEY HAVE THEIR COURT DATES AND
THEY MAKE THAT ASSUMPTION -- OR
THEY MAKE THAT CLAIM THAT, NO,
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BE LET IN
HERE BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT AN
ASYLEE PER THE LAW, THEY WILL
RE
BE REMOVED.
THESE GOVERNORS ARE CHEATING
THEM OUT OF THE PROCESS.
>> THEY WILL STILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE HERE IS THAT
THESE BORDER STATES AND BORDER
TOWNS SHOULD NOT BE SUBJECTED TO
THE UNDUE BURDEN OF THIS.
AND -- NEED I REMIND YOU
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS FLOWN PEOPLE
UNDER THE COVER OF NIGHT
>> WHEN THEY LAND IN A
DIFFERENT TOWN, CITY, THE PEOPLE
ON THE OTHER END KNOW THEY'RE
COMING.
THIS IS JUST DUMPING PEOPLE, YOU
KNOW, ON MARTHA'S VINEYARD OR IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. IN FRONT OF THE
VICE PRESIDENT'S PLACE TO OWN
THE LIBS.
THIS IS HURTING THE KIDS.
HERE'S THE THING THAT I, YOU
KNOW, ALICE, REPUBLICANS LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT DEMOCRATS OR
SOCIALISTS AND SO.
YOU KNOW, THESE ARE, IN MANY
CASES, VENEZUELAN ASYLUM
SEEKERS.
PEOPLE FLEEING A SOCIALIST
DICTATORSHIP.
WHY ARE THESE GOVERNORS THUMBING
THEIR NOSE AS PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMING AND FLEEING FROM A
SOCIALIST DICTATORSHIP WHEN YOU
GO AFTER DEMOCRATS AS
SOCIALISTS?
>> LOOK, I THINK A LOT COULD BE
DONE DIFFERENTLY.
I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING, TO YOUR POINT, JIM, THERE
SHOULD BE MORE COOPERATION
BETWEEN WHERE THE PLANES AND
BUSES ARE COMING FROM AND GOING
TO TO HELP MAKE SURE THERE IS
ASSISTANCE ON THE RECEIVING END.
BUT AT THIS POINT RIGHT NOW,
THIS IS THE WAY THESE GOVERNORS
WANT TO DEAL WITH IT.
IN NOTHING ELSE, IT HAS
CERTAINLY CALLED ATTENTION TO
THIS.
AND DEMOCRATS ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE CRISIS AT THE BORDER LIKE WE
HAVE NEVER BEFORE.
>> WE HAVE ALWAYS TALKED ABOUT
THE CRISIS AT THE BORDER.
THE ONES WHO HAVE PUSHED
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN REPUBLICANS
THAT SHUT THE DOOR ON THIS.
AND THERE'S A COUPLE POINTS I
WANT TO MAKE.
FIRST OF ALL, YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
FLEEING THESE DICTATORSHIPS.
WHAT'S SO IRONIC, IS A LOT OF
VENEZUELANS CUBANS AND
COLOMBIANS WERE SUPPORTIVE OF
DeSANTIS.
THEY WERE IN THE LAST ELECTION
AS WELL.
NOW, I CAUTION MY IMMIGRANT
LATINO BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN
THESE STATES, VENEZUELANS,
COLOMBIANS, CUBANS.
LOOK WHAT YOUR GOVERNOR IS DOING
PERHAPS TO YOUR FAMILIA.
THEY WANT TO KICK THEM OUT OF
THE COUNTRY BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE
THEY HAVE THE HUMAN DIGNITY WE
ALL BELIEVE THEY SHOULD HAVE.
AND I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE A
HUGE MISTAKE ON BEHALF OF
REPUBLICANS IN SEEKING THE
LATINO VOTE.
AND THE SECOND THING I WOULD SAY
IS THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
REPUBLICANS LOVE TO TALK ABOUT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DOING
THIS UNDER THE COVER OF NIGHT.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY WERE DOING
UNDER THE COVER OF NIGHT,
REUNITING THE FAMILIES THAT WERE
SEPARATED, BRUTALLY SEPARATED
UNDER THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THIS, BY THE WAY, JIM, IS NO
BETTER.
THIS IS AKIN TO THAT KIND OF
FAMILY SEPARATION.
IT IS EGREGIOUS.
IT IS INHUMANE, AND IT IS CRUEL
>> MORE THAN ANYTHING WHAT WE
ARE DOING IS CALLING THE
DEMOCRATS'S BLUFF.
VICE PRESIDENT HAIR HIS SAID THE
BORDER IS SECURE.
SIT NOT SECURE.
PEOPLE SAY THEY WILL WELCOME
THESE PEOPLE
>> THEY ARE WELCOMING THIS MEME
WITH OPEN ARMS, BY THE WAY.
>> DON'T USE KIDS TO MAKE A
POLITICAL POINT.